representing probabilities
for the two individual bits so that these equations
right here are satisfied.
These are the probabilities
that come from our vector and these are the
equations that must be true by the condition of independence,
but if we take a look at this
second equality right here, we see that it demands that
q0 times r1 is equal to zero,
but the only way that the
product of two real numbers can possibly be equal to zero is if at least one of those
numbers itself is equal to zero.
This is sometimes called
the zero product property of the real numbers.
Another way to say it is that the product of two non-zero real
numbers is always non-zero.
So this equality right
here implies that either q0 is equal to zero or r1 is equal to zero,
but from the first and the last equalities we see that neither of
those two alternatives can possibly be true.
If q0 is equal to zero, then this product must equal zero, but it's not equal to zero
and if r1 is equal to zero,
then this product must be equal to zero, but that's not true either.
So we have a contradiction
and we conclude that X and Y are not independent so they're correlated.
The notion of independence
that we just discussed and specifically is formulation in terms of probability
vectors is closely connected
to an operation that can
be performed on vectors known as the tensor product.
Tensor products can be
defined not only for vectors but also for matrices
and in fact the notion of a tensor product can be defined
for many other sorts of
mathematical objects as well.
They can be described
in a pretty abstract way that's both important and
useful in pure mathematics, but we can also define
tensor products for vectors
in a very simple and concrete way, and that's the path that
we'll take in this lesson.
If we have two column vectors Phi and Psi written in the forms that you see here where sigma and gamma are any
choice of classical state sets
we like or indices if you prefer, then the tensor product of these vectors is the vector that you see right here.
We range over all elements
of the Cartesian product of the two sets, sigma and gamma, and the entry of this
vector that corresponds
to each pair ab, which is
written as a string right here, is equal to the product of
the corresponding entries
of these two vectors. In other words, the ab entry of Phi tensor Psi is the product of the a entry
of Phi and the b entry of Psi,
and that's the meaning of
what's written down here.
In essence, this is the same operation that we just saw a few moments ago when we discussed independence
and now we're just giving a name to it.
Here's exactly the same example
that we saw a moment ago written more explicitly in
terms of the tensor product.
Again, we have that one sixth is equal to one quarter times one third, one 12th is equal to one quarter
times one third and so on.
Here, by the way are a
couple of alternative ways to write the tensor
product of two vectors.
When we're using the direct notation and we write two cats next
to each other like this, it means the tensor product.
So you can think about the tensor product as kind of being the default way to multiply to column vectors together.
It wouldn't make any sense
to think about a product of column vectors like this in terms of matrix multiplication because the dimensions don't work right,
so there's really no concern
about ambiguity here.
We can also write the
tensor product like this inside of a cat and it means
exactly the same thing.
It's the tensor product
of the two vectors.
The first one is very common and in fact it's perhaps more common to write a tensor product like this without the tensor product symbol
than it is to include the symbol. The second one is
definitely much less common, but it is sometimes quite helpful mainly
as a way to eliminate the need
for additional parentheses in certain situations.
We can also express
tensor products explicitly in terms of actual columns of
numbers as you see right here,
if we take the tensor product of these two column vectors right here, then this is the vector that we obtain
and you can see that the entries here are products of the entries
coming from these two vectors.
The ordering of the entries
of the tensor product is consistent with the
definition from a moment ago provided that we follow the convention
that I described earlier for ordering the elements
of Cartesian product sets.
Following that convention is equivalent to thinking
about the indices of the first vector as
having higher significance than the indices of the second vector,
so you can see that as
we go through the entries of the tensor product, we have all of the products involving the first entry of the
first vector on the left,
which is alpha one. Then all of the products
involving the second entry of the vector on the left,
which is alpha two and so on.
Here's an example where
the vector on the left has three entries and the vector on the
right has four entries so we can see more
clearly what's going on.